what's up my babies this is episode 160
of congratulations what up what up how's
it going hi dude nobody starts a podcast
like that
hi I do because you got to switch things
up you know you got to make sure you're
keeping it real you got to make sure
you're keeping it moving and so far I
know the podcast has only been going for
30 seconds but I've legitimately said
absolutely nothing worth anything so
it's all good come on but here comes
something important West Palm Beach
Florida there's very few tickets left
from a March 24 March 20th and March
21st show mmm I don't know if I'm gonna
add more my agent just hit me up and
said hey you want to do two more shows
and that's you know you want to do what
he actually said was do you want to do
two more shows that's but I'm not sure
you known I mean but I'm not sure
because I made just chill I may not want
to do it so there's like a few tickets
left it'll sell out so go get it now one
time a sponsor got mad that I did this
for work she thought it was so
disrespectful and they day were like
what we're not [ __ ] re-upping with
you guys and I was like do it you don't
get the [ __ ] podcast at all so rude
and so I did because that's yeah we
don't want you we don't [ __ ] want you
dude you don't get the humor we don't
want you we don't want you don't get the
humor we don't watch dude don't watch
when somebody isn't in the group dude
and they don't understand what's going
on and you see them and you're [ __ ]
popping off and you're having a good
time and you're laughing and they're
just like this we don't watch you
understand get out get out you know what
the whole thing you can sit with us how
they flipped it on you I flip it back to
you can't sit with us dude I'm a mean
girl I'm a [ __ ] straight-up mean girl
you understand that's me that's me baby
Krista leave the mean girl
and so that's gonna be how it's gonna be
West Palm Beach we're gonna come in and
and do it
Robinson Mississippi some reefs Rohnert
Park California some reefs and Las Vegas
in the Nevada you know why
and you know why dude and when I'm in
Las Vegas not really go I go to bed
pretty much the same time that I would
when I was in LA I put when people go to
Las Vegas then they just hang out until
like seven or eight or nine or ten dude
it's one thing to stay up until six you
know you want to see the Sun Rise you
want to see some [ __ ] you want to see
some [ __ ] that you wouldn't normally see
maybe you don't usually get up early
don't get to see us you're like I'll
stay up late and I'll see it seven oh
boy eight but dude one time I stayed up
till 10:00 I mean you don't understand
what's happening it's like one of those
movies where a guy wake you know where
they [ __ ] wash everything out and
you're and the guys just like hearing
like a high-pitched sound you know what
happy it's like when [ __ ] uh it's
like when the guy from Saving Private
Ryan is looking for his arm speaking of
which I saw this movie good time with
Robert Pattinson and one of those and
Benny safta softie
Benny softie they did that they directed
the Southie Brothers directed it and and
they also directed a uncut gems which
you probably know about I don't know if
you know about them of a good time but
it's a good movie man and goddamn man
these guys are good in it man the acting
is so good in this movie it rivals
[ __ ] Colin Firth and speak King
speech but the highlight dude it starts
with this dude
Benny softies playing him and I thought
he was mentally disabled for real but
he's not he's acting mentally disabled
and I'm like that's a real that's a guy
using acting to do that and how come
people aren't you know that the reason
why people aren't canceling him because
he's so good he's just like they ask him
questions he he's just like no
they're like hey so did this happen and
he's like no and you're like ah that
that sucks I feel bad for that guy and
he's just like boy right nut down I
don't want that down
I don't what don't written down and
you're like ah poor kid and then you
realize I goo tube the video of him and
he's just like talking like like a
regular dude he's just like well when we
first asked Adam Sandler to do the movie
I'm like what happened to [ __ ] no we
were not thrown huh well I got another
Christian Bale on our hands guy directed
it too and did the score and edited it
how's he doing it also the last name
softie [ __ ] rocks that says that's a
[ __ ] that last name is awesome and
dude
Robert Pattinson is such a good actor
dude that guy is [ __ ] so good every
time I see him in a movie I'm like and I
hate when people say this but do you
forget that it's the guy you're like oh
yeah I feel like I forgot it was the guy
you're like all right dude you're a
school teacher and you're just saying
[ __ ] but this guy Robert Pattinson is so
good
he's British dude what's he doing
playing a guy from Queens can't tell he
goes like this to his London accent he
goes like this don't watch and then he's
like hey what do you do and I use guys
and I'm just like damn dude he's so good
I'm the [ __ ] movie reviewer dude the
[ __ ] softie
you know softie brothers the last names
uncut gems got to see I got to see uncut
gems I haven't seen it yet but good time
is good my buddy said you got to see
good time and I was like okay and I was
like and he was like it's like one of
the best movies of the year and I he
kept talking about it so much and I got
really upset how many times you gonna
bring something up you know like I had a
buddy once he's a comedian his name is
Dean Del Rey on one-time dude I swear to
god he brought up the new MacBook Pro
that was coming out so much and one and
and the fantastic mr. Fox in one week he
wouldn't stop talking about the new
MacBook Pro that was coming out and
fantastic mr. Fox that was
now and I was like bro I don't give a
[ __ ] man one night at the diner I just
said hey man I want you to do me a favor
and I want you to listen to me man I
want you to stop talking about the
[ __ ] fantastic mr. Fox bro and he
started laughing so hard because he
knows that he brought it up for too long
and too many times and he knows he knows
that he was bringing up the MacBook Pro
for too many times dude get a MacBook
Pro don't get a MacBook Pro but stop
talking about how thin it is it was
unbelievable
he was just like oh yeah oh you got it
hey everything fantastic mr. Fox it's
not twice oh oh you gotta get the
MacBook Pro you see it oh my buddy Dean
is hilarious he's a comedian you should
follow him but dude he's so funny he'll
be he says the most basic [ __ ] sometimes
dude he'll be eating food and he'll be
like oh the flavor just like you mean
what propels food we mean the only
reason yay
like he'll listen to see the thing about
them that album is the sound
it's just killer and you're like all
right bro that you mean The Sound of
Music
it's unbelievable the collar and a
painting that he'll do that and I know
just throw my hands up I'll be like all
right bro you know so get specific Dean
but I like it though I like him because
of that one time we were in an argument
about he was in an argument with another
guy about a by a band the guy's rocks he
does mean he does music what he used to
do music when I was a comedian but dude
he and he's got a podcast called let
there be talk or let to be rock or some
[ __ ]
let there be talk cuz it's a podcast and
and he was talking about this guy about
he was like nah this guy on the band he
was like this one guy was like he was
like nah he's not like that and he was
like oh yeah it is it's that guy and he
was like nah it's not that guy and he
was like oh yeah it is and the guy said
how do you know and Dean lifted up his
shirt and had the guy's face tattooed on
his [ __ ] shank and I
I went home I immediately [ __ ] went
see you guys I went got in bed
immediately with all my clothes on
because bro you can't be like that
I got tattoos I gotta get all sorts of
tattoos this wife anybody gets in an
argument with me I just show them the
tattoos and they shut the [ __ ] up about
it they'd be like that's not right yeah
yeah
you are giving me about the moon are you
kidding me look at this and I [ __ ]
show you my left children I got the moon
on it well I think I got that because I
know so much about the moon and they got
Aaron in right in right so yeah so
anyway that movie is good good time and
I was why I want to keep say oh there it
is check out Dean Del Rey's sweet bond
Scott tattoo its bond Scott
well I don't know what it is look his
face in that picture you know I got to
get all tied it up bro I get all tied it
up my tattoo artist is always so busy
though and going around the world and
[ __ ] I want to get new ones I got to get
new ones I want to get [ __ ] tight
about the other day the other day I
looked at myself I tried on this shirt
or something I don't even remember
maybe I wasn't even but I was walking
through a mirror and I was in a clothing
store know that I don't wanna lie to you
guys you know I mean maybe I was trying
someone maybe I wasn't let's leave that
open dude you know I don't lie here so I
put my eye I had this I was clothed and
I was like wow it would be [ __ ]
pretty ripping if something was peeking
out of my neckline like if I just had
some [ __ ] like some wings or
something I know I'm not man I'm look I
know I'm gonna be 40 but I'm the young
I'm also the youngest man alive and bro
that [ __ ] would look banging dude I need
to get I want to get a crown tattooed
under my hairline hahaha dude do you
know how much [ __ ] you get for real if
you have a crown under your hairline not
that I want pie you know I'm not gonna
you know that's not me that's my style
but wow dude
you just got to be so comfortable and
also secretly uncomfortable to get a
tattoo bro how about Chris Brown got a
[ __ ] shoe on his cheek
oh hey Chris Brown got a tattoo of a
[ __ ] shoe on his cheek another guy
invented that shoe and then Chris Brown
got it on his face such a betta [ __ ]
[ __ ] move dude
ill you know ill
it's a Jordan 3 Chris Brown got a Jordan
3 dangling from his ear looks like a
tendril acid Jewish Chris Brown awaits
dude Chris Brown steamed uh yeah but
anyway like that's insane dude to get
the [ __ ] someone else made a shoe and
he put on the ciders face that guy's
mixed up huh
I don't even think it's mixed up to get
a face tattoo anymore I think it kind of
you know if that's you fine but Chris
Brown what is he 40 like you've been
around bro now you're getting a face
tattoo
I guess he covered the rest of them up
self up maybe it's maybe it's not so bad
ill dude but we so handsome I feel like
an old grandma what are you doing you're
so handsome would you do with your face
let me look at it let me look at it
you know like what is he doing do it Chu
dunes for cons but you doing dude yeah
dude I don't to get something like just
get like a [ __ ] that's why I got
animals I got a plane it doesn't have a
[ __ ] Delta symbol on it you know when
you have [ __ ] when you have a thing
on your on your thing it's weird enough
that guys tat I that's why I got it from
dr. Wu because I wanted to I liked his
art and I was like that's it that you
know like his art yeah whatever is it
there I'm the same way I'm a [ __ ] I
shot him as well got a tattoo of his
shoe on my forehead well my point is I
need more tattoos and my dude the dude
who does is always in Japan or some [ __ ]
I gotta get a new guy so who wants to
tattoo me man but I only get like cool
[ __ ] sexy as [ __ ] [ __ ] I need something
peeking out my neckline dude bro is that
Chris peeking out his neckline to Leah
yeah I got this here on the back wall
it's a it's a photoshopped art of the
Last Supper with me as Jesus -
sacrilegious feel like I'm going to hell
just cuz I hung it up and it's got all
the cat you know the pod can I screw on
it
you got Theo you got Craig you got all
the guys I talked about you got Bobby
Lee Bryan Cal and you got Andrew Santino
mark Hayes was acting on Co vo Brendan
Schaub Whitney Milan ochi my brother sam
and butters and Wade the dog and who did
it ray I got it right here ray Rob hey
design so thanks for that
yeah these face tattoos like what's post
Malone got always tired that's pretty
pretty pretty gung-ho about always being
tired like you know it's pretty gung-ho
about always being tired like you never
asked I got to do some some hey dude you
want oh wait was it oh never mind dude
yo do you want to go play some [ __ ]
kickball oh [ __ ] sorry man I didn't see
the tattoos under your eyes you know
what I don't get is this you know what I
don't get dude this was this reclining
seat argument this reclining seat
argument where the video went viral I
tweeted it when the dude was the the
lady reclined her seat and the bitch-ass
ho dude behind her was like punch in the
back of her seat because he thought it
was disrespectful that she reclined the
seat and the dude was just trying to
watch videos on his phone hey dude
you're a [ __ ] man if the see reclines
let it recline Johnnie Cochran
if the cebra class little recline but
dude let it recline man this seat
reclines and the guys like oh yeah yeah
I know people I can't believe there's
people out there that actually are like
no it's disrespectful to recline your
seat bro
I paid for it also the seat reclines
I'm not rejiggering the seat to make it
recline
it reclines therefore if my seat goes to
your [ __ ] taint swear it's gone take
it up with [ __ ] Delta man the [ __ ]
isn't my problem how about this check in
and get a [ __ ] better seats for your
seat reclines to the guys all in the
back wall bro just because you're in
confidence doesn't mean she shouldn't
[ __ ] be comfortable [ __ ] that I
cannot believe this [ __ ] ass dude is
trying to watch what is he trying to
watch some [ __ ] movie on his on his
privileged ass iPhone and he's just
bumping her head like that in the front
the lady's like 50 [ __ ] years old
this guy's be younger than me if you can
believe that and this guy what a [ __ ]
dude
of course he's got just a beard too and
a bald head those guys are the most abit
you know or the most submit guy is a guy
who's got hair this long and and a
completely shaved face and it's gelled
and and there's one little piece coming
forward you know oh [ __ ] he roses you
know he does he rolls his [ __ ]
sleeves up like this he doesn't like
this like against his [ __ ] the the
side that's so [ __ ] dude that he's
doing that and it makes me angry and I
want to I want to live with that girl
and take care of her even though she's
older than me because that's so insane
and insensitive to do that that guy's a
bitch-ass ho like let her recline she
paid for it
wow dude and I can't stop thinking about
when Peter Pablo says yeah and I said
Heineken because I live with it I love
it and they paid me for it in his song
cool how I keep thinking about that but
yeah dude that's so insane and so also
when I you don't understand man when I'm
and this happens rarely because I
[ __ ] check and also you know now
[ __ ] bags bags of course
[ __ ] fly first class but you know
when I was in the back back and somebody
goes and reclines into my [ __ ] chest
region guess what there we go
I'm dealing with something that's all
that's happening I'm relaxing as best I
can
with someone's face in my in my chest
I'll give him a massage dude cuz I
[ __ ] up and I know it and great I'll
make the best of a bad situation I
[ __ ] up
I'll give him a scalp massage I'll put
my feet over there you know torso and
give him a scalp massage like I'm some
monkey on their back helping out because
dude you [ __ ] up you got the last seat
you don't have to get the last seat air
everything about flying is uncomfortable
everything so just suck it up you think
we want to be here 30,000 feet in the
air
if it yeah I don't get it I don't get I
I don't like when people are
disrespectful I don't get how people
think that the reclining the seat thing
is disrespectful and you know what I
don't want to hear any of it anymore I
don't want to hear anybody being like
well it's consider it to know dude it is
not it is considerate it's actually
considered to not fly how about that
Drive when someone reclines when I when
I recline all the way back and it goes
into somebody's lap if I I hope it goes
back far enough to where I could open my
eyes and see them upside down and then I
want to say you're welcome I'm being
respectful because this is what I want
to do and we're all in this together one
time I was on the plane one time I was
uh I was on the plane and this guy I
like was trying to turn my TV on and I
was hitting the button on the TV in
front of it you know the headrest in
front of it and the guy turns around he
says this is my seat that's yours
and I was like bro it's crazy how people
just go 0 to 60 when they're in public
like already pissed off about their
situation
now you don't need to be like that I go
like that now you don't need to be like
that white telling me that sir people
were saying that Europeans don't recline
seats which is [ __ ] stupid do it I
see in British - it's just like Ola way
back all right
people saying British oh yeah Europeans
they don't recline seat so why because
they respect bro
no way yeah elite British people respect
but bro have you seen paper that law is
I have a sitting on my seat all the way
back in your [ __ ] penis that's what
I'll do and I'll start sucking it not
even gay [ __ ] it I don't care I've got
to keep my mouth busy on this floor go
quicker yeah I don't care all week long
all the way back to home I don't know if
there's a guy Oh ago by horn me
hopefully there's a go because they're
not paid no Deeping some [ __ ] weight
talk there's a penis or just use it it's
a pill I'm hopefully it ain't old
jiggling around a little bit proposed I
don't know if I like to put me but my
head either use one of your bulls or
your nub and swallow me [ __ ] see it's
warning me [ __ ] pillows you got a
child oh yeah I hope you got a child
cuz here we go we those British guys
don't respect [ __ ] man
[ __ ] you've seen Europeans bro
speaking of which I was at I was at
Equinox speaking of which I was at the
gym and and I and I [ __ ] was working
out and then I you know I work out to
keep the [ __ ] tax up on my back
because I need the [ __ ] camera crews
to keep rolling in because there's
movies that need to be filmed in the
[ __ ] outback I got a movie about a
rain forest coming in a shoot and
[ __ ] June so I got to keep that [ __ ]
beefy I got to keep picking stuff up and
putting it down because I got to keep
the back beef you understand
the other night I can fall asleep I kept
hearing and I was like what the [ __ ] is
going on I was like where is that and I
was [ __ ] pulling my hair out dude I
walked into the [ __ ] bathroom I got
two mirrors I faced a face and I looked
in one mirror through to the other
mirror and I was like oh [ __ ] I forgot I
have a rainforest on my back wildlife
anyway yeah so I was outside of the gym
Eden and [ __ ] Jason Statham walks out
and he's looking at me bro like Jason
Statham looks you know like he's looking
at me like you know he's looking at me
like I'm in a [ __ ] car and he can't
see who it is and I'm like what's going
on here and he's walking and look at me
not breaking my eyes my eye contact and
I'm like nothing's behind me I know
because I already studied because I know
my surroundings but when I sit down I
know what's behind me and what's behind
me now is a wall and it's about five
feet from me so I know he's not looking
at someone behind me and I know he's not
looking at the wall because guess what I
also figured out before I sat down the
wall is nondescript I'm a detective
all right you know what I am a Jason
Statham character so he's walking in
he's looking at me and his [ __ ] brows
are trying to meet you understand
they're like at a coffee shop they're
trying to get together it's their first
date and they're into each other all
right it's like if if the brows parents
saw them they'd be like want you guys
separate a little bit you're a little
bit too comfortable together but they
were trying to meet which means they
were together which means he was mad
dogging me in a bit but I knew it wasn't
mad dogging me cuz who the [ __ ] am i and
he's got his earphones in and he takes
his earphones out and he looks at me and
he stops and he says Chris and I was
like okay what's happening and I say
yeah and he says
he starts walking up to me and I'm like
huh and he says I thought that was you
but you know me old agent ho sometimes I
can't tell and I'm like I'm knee-deep in
a conversation with Jason Statham so I
stand up and he says are you doing Mike
[Laughter]
and I say I'm just eating after the gym
I'm just he says that thought I saw you
in that gym every now and then and I was
like yeah I'm just trying to get like
you are and I pat his back and I'm like
just [ __ ] patted iPad like what am i
doing you know and he says well hey you
trying to get look how I'll used to be
not like that anymore I got my dad bored
and I was like ah yeah well now you know
and he says yeah anyway he starts to
walk it away and then it comes back like
he takes four or five steps and then
comes back and he's like you know you be
what seeing if I'm thought of Dom or
whatever and I'm like yeah I was like
we're talking and [ __ ] and I was like
you let you live you're here what is it
yeah you know back and forth from London
and I was like yeah yeah yeah and he's
like well I don't remember I don't
remember what happened at that point it
was some kind of law but then he says
then I said so you you're you said dad
but I was like you are at that your dad
or well you got kids he says oh yeah
it's the thing about kids I was like
yeah I'm having my first like any day
now and he says oh you having a kid any
day now I was like yeah and he was like
that's really up that's really that's
really special night he was like well be
careful because you can't play in you
know you eat whatever it was it
whatever's in front of the kid to eat it
and then you're waited to before you
know you've been blowing up l2 here
you'd be like me and I was like yeah
yeah I was like yeah you won't see me
working out anymore over here I'll be
busy with the kid and he was like yeah
okay like I put a Chris he used to come
here oh it doesn't come anymore
oh they anyway I forget it's really
special you're about to be a dead that's
really awesome good luck to you and he
[ __ ] walks away and I'm like [ __ ]
happening eh sir Hollywood you know I'm
such a Jason Statham fan and it was so
dope dude
cuz he's so cool and I met him once
before you know I picked him a movie
idea I mean this was years ago and I
just I guess he remembers me from that
or maybe I don't know I don't know maybe
maybe you [ __ ] hey dude maybe he and
George my comedy ever [ __ ] forget
that but uh and anyway that was awesome
that was a good that's justice woman's
throat you and you realize man in
Hollywood when you do this [ __ ] you're
like man I'm in it I'm in it everybody
in the hollywood thinks they're not
Hollywood you understand like everybody
in Hollywood is like yeah but I'm not a
Hollywood guy yeah but that's not me I'm
not in Hollywood bro I was outside of
the gym eating barbacoa talking to
[ __ ] Shaw nothing more Hollywood than
that man hey dude you ever eat barbacoa
outside of Equinox while talking to Shaw
yeah Hollywood
I had my macro bowl
[Laughter]
dude you know like what's going on man
um so a Hollywood me
I'm mr. [ __ ] Hollywood dude guess
where I started stand-up Hollywood
that's where I started dude people are
like to be like I started stand-up in
Chicago I started stand-up in outside of
Boston I started stand-up in New York
and I did 45 spots a night [ __ ] that
dude I drove around Hollywood and
started I did some in WeHo I did some in
know how I did some in Soho and [ __ ]
Evo and those don't even exist do it
[Music]
Chris it's on [ __ ] it's so on
man
I'm basically [ __ ] Hobbs right
outside of equinox
I'm Hobbs bro all right dude let's do
some ads liquid-liquid Ivy believe it or
not a lot of people end up more
dehydrated in winter months isn't that
crazy
isn't that insane I learned that a while
ago and I keep hydrated during the
winter but it's hard dude because cold
weather makes dehydration harder to spot
so you're less likely to keep refilling
your water bottles and if you're
traveling dehydration makes jetlag and
headaches even worse take it from me
dude I got a headache every time I go
somewhere thankfully there's liquid ivy
the fastest most effective way to stay
hydrated
what makes liquid Ivy so effective well
cellular transport technology ctt ever
heard of it
you ever heard of ctt no but now you
have the optimal ratio of glucose sodium
and potassium delivers water and
nutrients into the bloodstream it's the
perfect balance to help you hydrate
quickly and more effectively than water
alone dude so you see what I'm doing
mmm that's not the best the best is with
liquid IV one stick of liquid IV and 16
ounce of water can give as much
hydration as two or three bottles of
plain water isn't that crazy
look
Ivy can provide the same hydration as
drinking two to three bottles of water
insane dude fuels tough workouts help
with a muscle fatigue promotes healthy
post-workout recovery you get it five
essential vitamins vitamin C more than
an orange and as much potassium as a
banana get 25% off when you go to liquid
IV calm and use code Congrats at
checkout that's 25% off anything you
order on liquid IVs website just go to
liquid IV comm and enter promo code
congrats to save 25% and get better
hydration that's liquid IV calm promo
code Congrats
don't wait start properly hydrating
today quit baby I keep my teeth clean
quit makers equip makers of the of the
quip electric toothbrush wants you to
know that one single discovery it
matters most for your dental care it's
simply this that if you have good habits
you're good that means brushing for two
minutes twice a day and flossing
regularly no matter what brand you use
quip now since you forget that a lot
because you Hillman it makes it simple
starting with elect an electric
toothbrush refillable floss and anti
cavity toothpaste quips electric brush
has sensitive sonic vibrations with a
built-in timer and 30-second pulses to
guide a full and even clean the quip
floss dispenser comes with pre-marked
string to help you use just enough plus
quip delivers fresh brush head floss and
toothpaste refills to your door every
three months with free shipping so your
routine is always right
three million healthy mouth join them
all up and get clipped today and if you
go to get clip comm / Congrats right now
you'll get your first refill free that's
your first refill free at get quip Calm
/ Congrats that's GE t qu i p.com / can
craft Congrats quip the good habits
company yeah man so hmm
that's what's up I'm having this baby
I'm having this baby any day now and and
pretty soon there's gonna be someone
even younger than me if you could
believe that the youngest man alive
becomes the [ __ ] second youngest man
alive
I can't wait for that people are like
yeah your life is gonna change and I'm
like dude no it's not I'm I'm gonna do
what I want I'm still gonna go out and
do spots it late at night and get coffee
will never ever [ __ ] say I walked you
I'll do whatever I want to go hang out
on the bud I'm gonna go hang out with my
buds no Gruff yeah but you need to
[ __ ] yeah I dude I'm selfish
yeah but don't you think you need to
spend time with the ride through the
world you're in for a rude awakening you
know um yeah dude one time when I was a
kid in the crib my mom walked in on my
dad holding a toy just out of reach and
I was trying to reach for it and grab it
out of the [ __ ] crib and my dad
wouldn't let me grab it and my mom said
bill what the [ __ ] are you doing and my
dad said teach him about life
[Laughter]
farted when a laughs couldn't held it in
dude it's so sexy to fart swear to God
sort of God swear to God one time when I
was in high school I [ __ ] fart it
couldn't help it somebody no dude I
messed up this story and it's fine
because it makes it better it's gonna be
like the [ __ ] movie where you think
one things happening and then you
realize at the end of the movie that
this is really what was happening Wow
his name was Doug dude you know when you
do something like fart or trip or
something embarrassing and people see
and they notice and you get so hot
inside you're like hold on a second does
anybody want to cook some bacon on my
chest cuz now's the time right you
almost feel tingly they start losing
your vision cuz you big puss that
happens to me well one time a kid named
Doug farted and he thought it was gonna
be I saw the way he was sitting he was
sprayed he's trying to spread his cheeks
you know and make it go but instead of
that I guess his butt was tight cuz it
went and it was in mr. Thatcher's class
and I turned around and I saw him and he
was doing this and I saw him feel hot
inside and it was so subtle but I
[ __ ] ripped cuz it made me feel human
I knew that he was feeling hot inside
just by his face and I was like that's
how that looks we be mean
wee-bey mean and so let's cut that on
the thing by the way on the video so
this way we know people know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about the wee-bey mean
from from with the wire you know what we
don't what you do [ __ ] yeah dude I've
been get rid of Ivan stay in the room
[Music]
one fire would never do that dude uh and
so uh so uh yeah what was I talking
about oh yeah so Doug [ __ ] farted but
what he should have done honestly was
said yup
ladies um ladies I'm free tonight that's
what you should do when you fart you
should immediately go ladies I'm free
tonight and not as a joke and not in
irony mean it [ __ ] yeah dude nothing
sexier than being you nothing sexier
than being you dude if you're boring be
boring
that's so goddamn sexy and own it dude
don't think you're good with chicks if
you're not if you're not then don't be
good with chicks and own it and all of a
sudden you're sexy sort of God you gotta
be you dude there's so many people out
there doing dumb [ __ ] like getting
[ __ ] really wide pants or like or
like getting like you know circular
glasses like these chicks with the
circular glasses or that everyone thinks
they're bad rabbit or would have [ __ ]
that guy's name bad bunny
everyone thinks they're bad bunny taking
pictures like this keep your tongue and
you [ __ ] mouth you're the same dude
like III really mean I'm a mean girl
dude and this is coming from a guy who
[ __ ] does that [ __ ] too so you know
it's real you know it's real fartin say
ladies drinks on me fart and then say I
guess I'm [ __ ] tonight what the [ __ ]
bad bunny put a third eye is that page
that a real thing that's not Photoshop
it's Photoshop he went out like that
with a third eye above his eye oh I mean
it doesn't even look good you know hey
dude you're [ __ ] so rich get a guy to
do it better
get the guy from the island to do it
that movie with Ewan McGregor and
Scarlett Johansson oh this looks like
[ __ ] chocolate looks like a cake um
dude bad bunny always makes the faces in
between the photos bad bunny is always
making a face of a face on the way to
making a face he this is a photo of bad
bunny he'll be like this
or like hey man you're on your way keep
going and then take the photo I posted a
picture of JLo on Twitter and I was like
goddamn she's [ __ ] 52 and she looks
like that and so many who were like
photoshopped and it's like bro
everything's Photoshop man she still
looks bangin that's JLo but dude stop
getting those [ __ ] weird glasses man
you're not bad bunny if you're bad bunny
cool bad bunnies the new prints do
whatever you want but don't be that guy
don't be um should I get a new [ __ ]
watch anyway dude
I guess should get Spence when you get a
kid but that's it man that's not it we
got like a bunch of a bunch of [ __ ]
times left one time I was driving
through [ __ ] New Jersey we were going
on a trip and my dad was stopped at a
toll and I was like dad how much longer
is it left and and he didn't know and I
said come on dad and I was like ask the
guy and it was such a cranky little
[ __ ] and I was like dad ask the guy
that's the guy in the taupe with our
masters and dad asked the guy how many
time did dad ask the guy how many times
is it like and I meant to say how long
is it gonna be and my dad said Chris
shut the [ __ ] up and he looked at the
guy and he says how many times is it and
then drove away dude that was so awesome
I never forgot it I never will my dad
looked at the guy he said how many times
is it and drove away the guy was
probably like what the [ __ ] who's that
guy that looks like George Harrison that
just asked me how many
time's is it if your dad didn't look
like George Harrison in the [ __ ] 80s
you're a robot
you were made not born or Mike Ditka you
know if your dad was white in the 80s
and didn't look like George Hammer
Harrison or Mike Ditka check your
circuits you know human dude every white
guy in [ __ ] 1984 looked like Mike
Ditka or George Harrison period if
you're lucky they look like the guy that
was on step-by-step the dad who ever
Cody's dad was but anyway um bad bunny
Wow
dude he's got a dreamcatcher on his chin
okay um anyway do it this Oh ads do ads
and then we'll talk about this other
thing I want to talk about honey buck
you've done it yeah your creative
passion is now your full-time job you
did it dude you understand you achieving
your goals but maybe you wish someone
would have told you how much time
drafting proposals creating contracts
and chasing down payments would take
this stuff that isn't your fav the good
news is that honey book is so helpful
with all those tedious admin tasks so
you can get back to doing what you love
which is the goal honey book is an
online business management tool that
organizes your client communications
bookings contracts and invoices all in
one place
okay so it's not confusing it's perfect
for freelancers entrepreneurs or small
business owners that want to consolidate
services they already use like
QuickBooks Google suite Excel and
MailChimp with honey book you can
automatic
you can automate your busy work they
have easy-to-use templates for emails
proposals brochures and invoices and
right now honey book is offering our
listeners 50% off when you visit try
honey book.com slash Congrats payment is
flexible and this promotion applies
whether you pay monthly or annually t ry
h o n ey b o ok dot-com / Congrats go to
try but try honey book.com / congrats
for 50% off your first year that's try
honey book.com slash
Congrats Bambi ba mbae when running a
business HR issues can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
when minimum wage requirements labor
regulations and HR - managers salaries
aren't cheap an average of seventy
thousand dollars a year dude okay
Bambi's spelled BA MBE was created
specifically for small businesses you
can get a dedicated HR manager craft HR
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just $99 a month with Bambi
you can change HR from your biggest
liability to big strength okay your
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email or real-time chat which is
great from onboarding determinations
they customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day to day all for just $99 a
month month-to-month no hidden fees
cancel anytime
go to bam be calm / congrats right now
and schedule your free HR audit that's
Bambi dot-com / congrats spelled BAM to
the B e.com
/ Congrats you did it guys text me eight
one eight two three nine seventy eighty
seven I do all that I text you back try
to if you're listening to this on the
plane I want you to recline your seat
right now and get it in that guy's lap
behind you that's what I want you to do
and then when he says hey don't do that
you say why I'm a respectful baby that's
what you do and then you point to him in
to say you stop being pasted [ __ ] and if
you do that let me know about it talking
about hot again cuz they because I like
it and they pay me for it people oh dude
this Buffalo Wild Wings thing
it's just insane dude the Buffalo Wild
Wings thing pull it up is when
they the Astros got caught cheating in
like what 19 mm some year they won the
World Series and I guess that they just
came out that they were cheating or
something right something like that
no you don't know yeah basically very
basically if I'm wrong who gives you
[ __ ] basically it so so the the coach or
the whatever the [ __ ] was like
apologizing kind of and be like jeers
never win so we didn't win so don't
worry about it whatever he did was the s
dick about it you know and so also you
better believe if I was playing baseball
I would be cheating so hard like there's
no way I wouldn't be cheating I would be
betting against us and then not playing
as well I would be like saying nah
that's not what happened I will be doing
that kind of [ __ ] all day long that's
not what happened I'd be throwing people
under the bus that's not what he [ __ ]
dude that's why I'm the catcher because
he [ __ ] did that I should be right
field and they'd be like oh oh you know
this is what the Lea says and some other
guy would be like no and then I hope I
would get the leg up in a cheating
fashion you understand cuz it's just
baseball and I'd be raking in Mills but
so Rob Harris tweets breaking manchester
city band breaking manchester city band
from champions league for two seasons by
f a-- and find 30 million euros UEFA FA
and so but so Buffalo Wild Wings rights
that's how you punish a team that cheats
and I guess people fought and I wouldn't
even have known but I guess Buffalo Wild
Wings change it was saying that was
insinuating about how to ask that astro
should be punished so Houston took to
Twitter and started roasting them first
of all Houston I love you I legitimately
you're one of the cities I like going to
and performing in the most
I love Texas dude and you know I
wouldn't say this right now if I wasn't
serious I love Dallas I love Austin
I love Houston San Antonio is it and I
[ __ ] love Texas
because Houston sure it's hot but it's
also bangin everyone there is either a
hot chick or a tall corn husking dude
love it Dallas love how the girls go out
with the hair that looks like
Battlefield Earth just sprayed up like
it's 1987 love the dudes in Dallas that
won't not tuck in their shirts no matter
what the outfit love Austin sure it
pisses me off that the slogan is keep
Austin weird because you're not funky
you're just a city with a bunch of
weirdos in it that and every one out of
every eight people has a mustache
including the girls because they think
it's interesting but they're still
banging okay and everyone's there for
music but Austin love yeah
San Antonio you have the Riverwalk and
everybody's drunk right now listen love
Texas okay but Houston and I hate saying
this dude but we have a problem
because dude the thing is you became a
little bit of a [ __ ] when Buffalo Wild
Wings change it happened to say this
thing about Manchester and the FA all
right because you started saying well
I'll never eat there again cutting up
Houston Buffalo Wild Wings [ __ ] cards
by the way what kind of a [ __ ] fat so
are you that you have a Buffalo Wild
Wings membership card hey guy cut that
up anyway guarantee you were sweaty when
doing it also
it's 2020 who's eaten wings who still
eat wings dude you know the last time I
put a [ __ ] wing in my mouth
at a party a few years ago cuz I was
starving and that's all that there was
and I got there late dude you should not
be eating wings man that's gross
hookers or [ __ ] whatever the hooters
that place [ __ ] legitimately thought
it was named hookers for a second click
come on man what is this place
hooters dude hey dude for real just call
it hookers hooters no don't call it
hookers because I believe those girls
should be making that money and you
should be tipping those girls and those
girls are working hard and some of them
got a [ __ ] family to provide for I
like those girls you're you're you're
you're you're trying to make that money
and you're being positive in society but
company just call your place tits you
know uh anyway these [ __ ] people in
Houston were like look at this look at
this let's just pull up some of these
find some of them in the woods and we'll
just come on dude was my twitter app
we're my twitter at go to some of them
want to go to got this gift for
Christmas look at this by the way got
this gift for Christmas they're cutting
up the Buffalo Wild Wings card dude you
got that gift for Christmas from a who
someone that [ __ ] hates you
hey dude that's Buffalo wow that's a
Buffalo Wild Wings gift card dude sad
hey guy that's cool also sad look at
this guy Kenny Swift this cuck let this
cook name by the way and you just lost
business in the 4th largest city in the
US and surrounding areas that's how you
punish social media accounts that pop
off with a DJ Khaled jiff that says
congratulations
please yourself Kenny Swift with the
[ __ ] profile pic of that cat that
that lady's yelling at or whatever the
[ __ ] it is dude shut up man shut up by
the way the Houston Astros cheated so
you're coming in to defense for people
that robbed money in base in baseball
you butthurt
Kenny Swift couldn't sound more like a
[ __ ] country singer by the way
goddamn that's so ridiculous that they
troll [ __ ] you [ __ ] it dude uh houston
you're being a the people in houston
that are doing this you're being a [ __ ]
you're being a straight-up [ __ ] dude
you're being a butthurt [ __ ]
dude I would have I don't eat wings I
wanted to run to Buffalo Wild Wings and
get all the wings and put him in my
pockets and they'd be like you want a
bag and I go are you kidding me dude I'm
wearing these no bag [ __ ] that they go
in my pockets wings and then this
happened get ready to be pissed my
babies Buffalo Wild Wings pulls the even
more [ __ ] move and they tweet back a
day later so last night was the roast of
Buffalo Wild Wings courtesy of the city
of Houston and honestly we deserved it
well done h-town for coming to your
team's defense and we're sorry about
what we posted hey Buffalo Wild Wings
you just solidified something I'll never
eat there because you went back on an
opinion that first of all doesn't matter
and now it's new
and now I know about it and I'm not
eating there and guess what
Buffalo Wild Wings and I'm serious about
this next time I see my friend Jason
Statham I'm telling not to [ __ ] eat
there too so that's two [ __ ] huge
equally famous guys that are not going
to go to Buffalo Wild Wings anymore
God how I imagine being sorry about it
about making fun by the way Buffalo Wild
Wings why are you even tweeting about
this the only thing you should be
tweeting about is hey we got wings
that's every tweet that Buffalo Wild
Wings should tweet should be them saying
hey we got wings or reminder : we got
wings or hey do you like our wings or
hey you must like our wings
why are you tweeting about the Astros at
all but if you do tweet about the Astros
do it once and if you take a stance and
pop off in a humorous way and then you
feel the heat welcome to my world you
bitch-ass but don't apologize for it
especially when you know you're right
see this is why I can't do I can't trust
you [ __ ] now because you did
something that you thought you stood
behind and then cuz the mob came running
the fat sweaty palms Buffalo Wild Wings
eatin [ __ ] gift card having as gift
certificate [ __ ] they kept
coming you guys felt the heat and
apologize about some [ __ ] that you know
is right and you know that you still
stand behind or you don't and you change
your mind because these [ __ ] Fatso's
find then you know what I don't trust
you so how can I trust what you give to
me to put inside my body wings
no don't eat wings by the way dude
unless you want to get cancer they're
smothered and radioactive [ __ ] hey
dude they're orange don't eat anything
that's orange except and orange for real
man that's crazy dude [ __ ] Buffalo Wild
Wings beat Buffalo Wild Wings
that's awesome when I do it like that
beat Buffalo Wild Wings beat Buffalo
Wild Wings hell yeah dude that's awesome
I'm glad I figured that out this is a
silly goose time I'm [ __ ] I have no
style never have I mean dude I can't
believe I have the sponsors I have for
real I talked to my guy sometimes it
gets me paid to do social media posts
once or twice maybe and I'm like how
come these [ __ ] aren't dude I
see these people out there doing [ __ ]
give me money to [ __ ] talk about you
and he's like yeah well a little bit of
a loose cannon yeah dude [ __ ] you [ __ ]
Buffalo Wild Wings this is grassroots
bro I'm Bernie Sanders the mean girl I'm
Bernie Sanders do it
imagine if Bernie Sanders wins that's
gonna mobilize the right like these
[ __ ] Houston Buffalo Wild Wings
eating [ __ ] who by the way are
the same people there's no crowd there's
the crossover is 100% go right dude I
can't iii-it's so I can't something
about this baklava Benson I can't
believe people would be mad at Buffalo
Wild Wings in Houston and not want to go
there now because that's what they said
first of all and then for Buffalo Wild
Wings to apologize for it's just
unbelievable
if Bernie wing wins dude Wow
you don't know my political stances you
don't know who I vote for and I like it
like that
I make fun everybody
Trump has an insane person
if Bernie wins do it Wow it's gonna be
insane if Bernie wins it it will be
[ __ ] insane if Bernie wins we will
live in the craziest time of our lives
that's all I'm saying I'm not saying
maybe I'll vote for her maybe I won't
you don't know dude
you don't know well you do know is I
like Buddha jesh and one time I was
talking about Buddha jej and I was like
I like that [ __ ] I think he's
got a shot and dude this was way back
when nobody gave a [ __ ] or you know
except for like some people and wherever
the [ __ ] is from what is it Ohio where
is he from Iowa Idaho some weird ass
Idaho Iowa Ohio there's to be states
that sound like that anyway
Indiana that's what it is I knew we were
too many thousand so and some dude
tweeted me and I remember he was like my
man Chris D'Elia thinks Budaj edge has a
shot and did crying laughing emojis this
school has a 0% polling yeah bro he's a
front-runner now you [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass it's front row now [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass dude I would love to see Budaj
edge and [ __ ] Trump just talk I would
love to see that that would be my
favorite because I think Bernie will get
flustered I think Bernie could lose his
cool bootie judge well well that's not
true Trump facts facts facts facts facts
facts facts and Trump will just be like
oh yeah you look like Alfred E Newman
man I would love to stop at the WWF WWF
welcome to live W W do ya man anyway I
just love that no matter who gets picked
there's a smear campaign against them no
matter what that's why that what Trump
did was just own it was just amazing
dude I mean God that guy's a [ __ ]
lunatic straight-up but he was like yeah
I [ __ ] did all that stuff
oh you're too sensitive real long you
know anyway whatever the diehard
[ __ ] are the craziest dude that
diehard [ __ ] for anybody are
the craziest like the guy you're
following could be wrong
did you know that he's not even you
you know I'm saying you know saying he's
not even you
you don't even stand behind what you
stand behind that much but people are
like now [ __ ] dad Barney
Trump you don't even stay it's not even
you dude that's another body that's away
from you I'm a mean girl and that's
about it I've got other stuff I could
talk about but bro you know how many
things I had written down in this
podcast man how many things I had
written down three three things too
- I had two things one fire turned into
one higher because he told me I had two
things written down I had two things
written down right before I sat down I
had [ __ ] Jason Statham written and
then I had another thing written that I
forget what was it one fire doesn't even
know back to one fire and so because I
didn't remember it it doesn't matter
because that's how unimportant it is and
then also he said hey why don't you talk
one fires and want to talk about the
Buffalo Bob leg thing and I was like you
know what that's a good thing so that
was the third thing so now I did an hour
okay
I wrote down [ __ ] two things and one
fire had one thing and and I did it dude
and I did it for you but make no mistake
dude even though I lie I'm not lying
about this I did it mostly for the money
I did it for the sponsors that are
paying me because you know what I do it
because I love money
I love having money and I love paying
for things and buying things and
walking out of the place where I bought
it and being like this doesn't matter
my life's the same my life's the same
when the money subtracts and also my
life is absolutely the same whether I
get the [ __ ] thing or not which is so
sad
really I'm a consumer I'm a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] is what I'm trying to say
I'm a piece of [ __ ]
but also it's okay to feel like that but
also I'm a person and I'm human guy that
was more what I just said was more
unimportant than what wise said in the
first 30 seconds of the podcast so
anyway maybe I should have a guest soon
like a real guest you know what dude I
should have a real guest I'm not having
a guest until I can have a [ __ ] super
crazy famous person if you want if
you're listening or if you know somebody
that's super famous suggest whoever
tagged him on Twitter and tell him that
they should be the first guess it'll be
good for them this podcast is enormous
okay people that are like even super
famous like not Elon Musk of course he's
not gonna do it but I'm talking about
people that are like movie stars and
[ __ ] there's a big podcast dude I
mentioned Buffalo Wild Wings we got to
mobilize dude we got to mobilize dude if
ice babies really have to mobilize I'm
trying to be that Bernie Sanders
[ __ ] that Donald Trump
[ __ ] that just says what goes
dude yeah all right guys well yeah tell
him on Twitter and if you know somebody
that knows somebody that knows somebody
you should tell them hey Chris Lee's
looking for a first guest you should do
it Sam Jackson or whoever the [ __ ] you
know all right guys you guys are great
and thank you very much oh [ __ ] I got a
look at the back here you can text me at
whatever the [ __ ] number is and also
man of course it's the last it's always
the last place you look right it's
always the goddamn last place you look
there it is dude the last card I looked
at is what it is support the show by
buying merch oh the the life
Rip's hoodies the-the-the tie-dyed ones
are gonna be back in business very soon
here this week they're going to so there
they sell out immediately the black ones
sell out even quicker but we're doing
the tie-dye ones now again and subscribe
to the YouTube channel please subscribe
to the YouTube channel
it really helps it helps us by putting
you know I still em in the back of my
head thinking about doing some weeks
where I do two a week and I can do that
if the numbers go up because I just it's
it I can do it now and it's worth it
because you know for the podcast I can
make more money but I also don't want to
like dilute it but if the numbers are
that much better then forget it do it
I'll do it I will do it so subscribe to
the YouTube channel
listen share it try and grow this cult
because this is this cult dude and
you're not doing your [ __ ] due
diligence it's a baby if you're not
helping to grow the cult where your
merch at other people's other comp
comedic comedians shows especially Bryan
Callen in a loving way not in a [ __ ]
any other way than a loving way because
we love and support all comedians man we
do so yeah I got my special coming out
soon dude I don't I can't tell you yet
it's not official the date but it's 99%
sure and I can't wait to tell you and
it's soon and it's soon my babies it's
soon my videos so West Palm Beach to
finish up those tickets get those at Las
Vegas we got some new August agents in
Las Vegas and I think my Atlantic City
thing just went on sale I don't know
what I'm going to do it Atlantic City
very soon
so keep checking the website for that
and the light rips merch and all the
other merchants ooh silly goose time
ladies and you got it my babies you guys
are great thank you very much this is
coming from me me and girl crystal it
[Music]